la mia capacità di non stupirmi più di
una sega
mi sorprende sempre di più bella a tutti
i ragazzi e benvenuti su cell simulator
con un simbolo palesemente copiato da un
altro famosissimo videogioco però sono
sicuro che anche questo non sarà da meno
mio games che gates jarvis fillon
francis che un dj speriamo che questo
video non sia completato c'è mister
vista tutti youtuber non ci sono io
quindi già votiamolo male sociale da
avere io sceglierei cc da os controllo
vsd luxit da un bellissimo che sembra
che stava all'idea netflix pre il video
youtube che cazzo sto guardando cosa sto
vedendo su cosa sto cos'è cos'è cos'è
sta roba
cosa sto giocando set up per alimentare
la parte il fatto che nella grafica fa
schifo a google music bella tempo giusto
perché mi sembra che mary fallin share
place share
fellay confort babel piazza la piazza la
come si piazza f to play su ok ma io ve
lo piazzava la in fondo alla news
bening ds a ome terra certamente la ci
sono in sit points in alto a sinistra
che ti permettono di comprare altre
serie cioè io avrei coast e io con lei
in quanto sono stato seduto alla mia
vita avrei potrei comprarmi tutte le
serie che vendono nel mondo arriva in
prove c'è il sound one percent solo 1
per cento disegni size generating slowly
bisogno di dire anche mi sta facendo
male il culo cosa vuol dire uno stock
appello scusatemi
dove sono le altre sedi e come faccio il
gioco era come sto buttando via il mio
tempo raggiungendo alla fine di prè in
inglese a ome terre
adesso sto perdendo punti alzati o muori
addirittura non va bene solo di vedere
la prima per curiosità voglia dire
quanto tu possa morì in che modo poi
morire su una sedia sono morto
hai perso tutte le tue serie two is it
points vabbè tanta scritta aiuta il
palesemente di dark souls che possa
scegliere anche questo come personaggio
c'è bisogno di ngo bob hitler ma che
cazzo ma cos'è ma non è neanche un
personaggio sta roba buy in di essa o
meter
vabbè aspettiamo un busto usando bingo
bob perché mi sembra carino quindi
usiamo vincolo ma io mi alzo e mi siedo
cioè sostanzialmente l'unico modo mi
alzo e mi sembra la porta la posso usare
si può presentare
ma di che parliamo ma cos'è ma cosa sto
ma cos'è ma che parcheggio blur tomaia
preso una foto parcheggio nemiche ha
comunque ci si perde qua dentro e non
leggo c'è il romano quanti punti vuole
la quale la segna più a ford monella le
gocce fa un male al culo che la metà
basta e volevo dirvelo cassina ufficiale
a questa qua plastic sul credo che man
mano che vai avanti tu farmi punti più
velocemente quindi sostanzialmente serve
per comprare sedia di maggior lusso tra
cui una sedia da gaming che non è male
va bene alle usciamo usciamo riuscire
voglio andare a far mare che contenuti
vi porto sul che va nessuno ha portato
starò io sì iscrivetevi maledizione per
altre cagate del genere solo sul mio
canale because esco a sedermi e fermare
almeno 50 punti perché studio
servono quelli vetro la una sedia un po
più performante di punteggio però fa
bene bingo non ti fermare il culo è che
qua è difficile suo gioco mi raccomando
ragazzi sempre sfilata neanche power
saprebbe giocare e abbiamo raggiunto 50
sit points bar se la prendo da posto
anche sei stancato a prenderla per gli
accordi col comunque place share
perché dopo non capire se potevo
venderla perché ci sono di carne che poi
venderle corde però era giusto per dove
mi chiami sono seduto a ho trovato un
pouf però a comprare questo anche questo
è bene ancora forte bambini non so
quanto effettivamente convenga però
vediamo by certo cup che nightbook
questo poi invece non piazzare per
maniglie posso anche sedermi qualora
farmo punti all'ikea facciamo prima cioè
non ha senso però quanto ci vuole per
comprare un miliardo di sé stiamo qua
tutto il tempo della mia vita parte foto
che ne quello di alzare quanti ne vuoi o
sbaglio no adesso lo sono ancora seduto
io ma campione cosa ma non è vero però
si possa andar si può barga riportiamo
da rimpiazzo due sedute 2 fisso l'altra
segniamo in treno non mi dai ducali
punti non sarebbe di interessante una
con questo fatto che ti puoi tenere dove
cacchio è bene non è che posso fare lo
faycal dicendo qua beni bejan confort ma
alcune vecchie e tutto veri ancora reti
al confort gol ma lo blog jayer fa
veramente tutto schifo 4 avesse io mi
siedo comunque mi sembra roba non vedo
perché no insomma è un po pagato sto
gioco secondo me cioè con alcune cose
vanno altre non vanno
prima a me faceva 3 vecchio missili via
place share con calabria piazza diamo
tre adesso 32 a per due multiplex e
segna da 1x2 fa due porco deposito devo
fare la devo fare così ogni volta ce lo
farei place di cap stato commentato da
l'inventario place share
ogni tanto bene da tre ma la cosa non
l'ho capita forse dovevo fare così
aspetta aspetta che mai suonato qualcuno
forse mi sa dare una mano aspetto allora
ragazzi o una persona che sicuramente ci
può venire a dare una mano beni amico
mio ben vedere quindi allora non
chiedere chi sono perché non lo so c'è
una cosa che tipicamente sono un nuovo
per born from si muove collegato infatti
sto veramente staglieno bingo bob vabbè
allora venite e questo gioco è un gioco
molto di strategia tipo i giochi bayern
puramente tu metti le sedie per terra e
farmi punti sedie che sono quelle man
mano che stesse l'uno di vista sento
troppo che sono più di toglie punti
perché ti fa male cure io ho il
moltiplicatore per due quindi questa
sedia per ora mi ha sempre dato un punto
questa sedia anche ti dà un punto solo
che però dà molto più velocemente no se
per 2 a 2
ok se io mi siedo qui fa 3 e poi da
tutti uno qui quale matematica stanno
adottando secondo velino la grecista un
po questo sì ma per che cosa la
rischiosità di più
ok il trono è quello che
qualitativamente mi da piu punti al
minor prezzo quindi è la madre quarta si
parlano punti che la metà basta e
ragazzi questo è veramente un fard i
punti interessante per i nostri amici
però il secondo me dopo 35 minuti
passati a giocare a questa roba io
passerei effettivamente la palla
all'altro perché secondo me intrattieni
di più l'altro che questo video ciò però
non c'è mai realmente facciamo stato
discorso con cui siamo al 75
un gioco che merita che premia
soprattutto è la dedizione quindi questa
cosa è molto importante bel gioco
scaricato ragazzi c'è il simulator vero
ragazzi mi sia piaciuto non è giuro che
non era un placement all'ikea questo
duro mentre giocava sta roba of armato
almeno duemila punti di sedia
soprattutto perché questa serie a ti
porta un sacco di punti molto di queste
tra l'altro che sarà chelsea un editor
quasi vent ragazzi mi piace non mi piace
anche marito già minato da schizzare
senatore di an come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo vito bella ragazzi
[Musica]